We're on 76.
In the figure below, line
AB is tangent to
circle O at point A.
Fair enough.
Secant BD intersects circle
O at points C and D.
Secant just means that
it intersects the
point at two points.
It's not tangent.
A tangent intersects the circle
at exactly one point.
Secant BD intersects the circle
at points C and D.
Measure of arc AC is equal to 70
degrees, and the measure of
arc CD is equal to
110 degrees.
So what do they want
us to figure out?
What is the measure of ABC?
So what is this angle?
That's what they want
us to figure out.
They want us to figure
out this right here.
That angle.
Let's see what we can do here.
So there's a couple of ways
to think about it.
Well, if you look at it, this
is 70, this is 110, right?
So if you add them, this whole
arc, going for all the way
around, that's 180 degrees.
So it's actually perfectly
halfway around the circle.
So actually from A to
D is actually a
diameter of the circle.
How do I know that?
Because it goes all the
way around the circle.
The arc length is 180 degrees.
So we can draw-- let me
draw a diameter line.
I don't know if this thing
is drawn to scale.
A to D is actually a diameter
of the circle.
We know that, because that's 180
degrees, the combined arc
length right there.
And we know, that this line
is tangent at point A.
So that has to be
a right angle.
When you're tangent at point A,
that means your tangent to
the radius at that point.
Fair enough.
So now let's see what
we can figure out.
We know that this arc
length is 70.
Is there any way to figure out
what this angle right here is?
Because if we know this angle,
we know this is 90, then we
could figure out that angle.
And this is something that you
should just learn about
inscribed angles in a circle.
This is an inscribed angle,
because the vertex touches on
one of the sides
of the circle.
So an inscribed angle-- and this
is just something good to
memorize, and you could play
around with it to get a little
bit more intuition about it--
is equal to half of the arc
length that it intersects.
So this inscribed angle
intersects an arc
length of 70 degrees.
So this is 35 degrees.
And that's just something
good to know.
That this is going to
be half of whatever
this arc length is.
Now we can figure out x, because
x plus 35 plus 90 is
equal to 180.
You get x plus 35 is equal to
90. x is equal to 90 minus 35
is 55, which is choice C.
Now there's another way you
can do this, and this is
another interesting thing
about lines that
intersect in circles.
It's that this angle measure,
right here, if it's sitting
outside of the circle-- I think
there might be ones
sitting inside the circle later
on-- but if it's sitting
outside of the circle, it's
equal to 1/2 the difference of
the arc measures that
it intersects.
So for example, it intersects
this arc measure of 70, and it
also has this arc measure
right here.
When it hits the circle and
intersects at 70 degrees and
when it exits the circle,
it has this arc measure.
This arc measure we already
figured out.
It's 180 degrees, because
that's 180 degrees.
So you know that this angle
right here, you could say that
x is equal to 1/2 the difference
of these two arc
measures, and we can do
that because x is
outside of the circle.
If x was inside the circle, then
x would be 1/2 the sum of
the two measures.
So what's the difference?
It's 180 minus 70.
So that's equal to 1/2 times
110, so that is equal to 55.
So it's nice to see that math
works correctly no matter how
you do the problem.
Problem 77: In the circle shown
below, the measure of
arc PR is 140 degrees.
Sure enough.
The measure of angle
RPQ is 50 degrees.
OK, that's 50 degrees.
What is the measure of arc PQ?
What is this arc right there?
So we could use what we learned
in the last problem.
50 degrees is an inscribed
angle.
So it's going to be half of
the arc length measured in
degrees, or arc angle, I guess
you could say, of the arc that
it intercepts.
So this is 50, then this
arc measure is
going to be 100 degrees.
So what we're trying to figure
out, this arc measure right
here, it's whatever you
really have left over.
Let's call this x.
So we know that x plus 100 plus
140, well, that goes all
the way around the
circle, right?
That's going to be equal
to 360 degrees.
So you have x plus 240 is
equal to 360 degrees.
Subtract 240 from both sides,
and you get x is
equal to 120 degrees.
Choice D.
Problem 78: The vertices of
triangle ABC are A is 2 comma
1, B is 3 comma 4, and
C is 1 comma 3.
If triangle ABC is translated
one unit down-- so one unit
down means that we're
subtracting 1 from the y's--
and three units to the left--
so that means you're
subtracting 3 from the x's-- to
create triangle DEF, what
are the coordinates of
the vertices of DEF?
So let's see, we have
A is 2 comma 1.
And that's going to be
translated to point D.
What do they say?
One unit down.
One unit down means the
y decreases by 1.
So the y-coordinate's going
to be-- decrease that
by 1, you get 0.
And three units to the left,
that means you decrease the
x-coordinate by 3.
So 2 minus 3 is negative one.
Actually, just looking at the
choices, we're already done.
D is the only choice that had
a negative 1 comma 0.
But let's look at
the other ones.
Maybe somehow they changed the
lettering or something.
Let's see point B
was 3 comma 4.
So what do we do?
With x, we said three units
to the left, so that
becomes point E.
So you take this three
units to left.
You're subtracting 3 from
there, that becomes 0.
If you take the y-coordinate
one unit down,
that becomes a 3.
So E is 0 comma 3.
So that's still consistent
with this.
And let's just make sure
that the F works.
So C was 1 comma 3.
If we take 3 away, we shift it
to the left by 3, so that's
taking 3 away from the
x-coordinate, so
that's minus 2.
And if you're shifting the
y-coordinate down one, that's
taking 1 from it, so that's 3,
so F is minus 2 comma 2.
And so D was definitely
the answer.
Problem 79: If triangle ABC is
rotated 180 degrees about the
origin, what are the coordinates
of A prime?
OK, so we're going to rotate
this thing 180 degrees.
And essentially, we can worry
about all the coordinates, but
they just want to know where A
prime is, so wherever A sits
after we've rotated it.
So let's think about
it a little bit.
When we've rotated the C, this
is going to be the new C.
It's going to be right there.
B is going to be, when you
rotate it-- I just want to
make sure I'm doing
this right.
This is almost like a
visualization problem.
If you go four to the
right and up three.
So if you were to rotate
it around.
Let's say this little arrow I
drew with the four, if I were
to rotate that 180 degrees-- I
just want to make sure I do it
right-- then that's going
to be four this way.
So you're going to
be at that point.
And then instead of three up,
you're going to go three down.
So that's where A prime
is going to be.
Right at that point.
And that's the point minus
five comma minus four.
And that's our answer.
But let's figure out all
of the other points.
So B, you go up three and
to the right two.
The new B, you'd go three
down to the left.
OK, it would be there.
So that's the new B.
Right.
And so that looks right.
That's what the triangle
is going to look like.
This is B prime, this is A
prime, this is C prime.
This is the new triangle when
you rotate it 180 degrees.
That was a challenging
visualization problem, but the
key thing is just to
keep visualizing
going around 180 degrees.
So minus five comma
minus four, that's
choice A for A prime.
Problem 80: Trapezoid ABCD below
is to be translated to
trapezoid A prime, B prime,
C prime, D prime by the
following motion rule.
What will be the coordinates
of vertex C prime?
OK, so that's all we have
to worry about.
We're at C and we're going to
translate it to some C prime.
What of the coordinates of C?
x is equal to five, and
y is equal to 1.
So what's C prime going
to be equal to?
C prime, we'll just use
this mapping rule.
You add 3 to the x, so it's
going to be 8, and you
subtract 4 from the y.
1 minus 4 is minus 3.
8 minus 3.
That's choice D.
And we're all done.
We're all done with the entire
California Standards geometry
test. And frankly, I started
off grumbling a little bit,
because I thought they were
getting a little bit too
obsessed with the terminology.
But overall, I think this was a
pretty good test. And if you
understood every problem on this
exam, I think you know
your geometry pretty well.
Anyway, see you in the next
video, although this is the
last in this geometry series.